In today's interconnected world,
we're constantly barraged by conflicting
information on what we should and
shouldn't be eating, but if there's
one thing that we can all agree,
should definitely not be part of our
diets, hits nuclear waste in the movies,
ingesting radioactive materials like
uranium results in all sorts of crazy
hi-jinks like a painting superpowers,
but what would happen if
you ate it in real life?
How would it change your body and how
do we know that we're not eating it? Oh,
ready.
This is what if,
and here's what would
happen if you ate uranium.
Uranium is a naturally
radioactive material.
That was one of the main elements used to
make the nuclear bombs of World War II,
but you don't have to be a mad
scientist to be exposed to it.
The environmental protection agency says
that the average person eats up to 1.1
micrograms of uranium per day.
How was it getting into our food and how
much can we eat before it starts to do
damage?
I know what you're thinking.
I wash and inspect every piece of food I
put into my body and I've never noticed
any glowing green materials. Well,
it's not that simple. For one thing,
contrary to what pop culture tells you,
uranium and most other radioactive
materials do not actually glow,
and on top of that,
the uranium we eat isn't being secretly
sprinkled on top of our food by some
covert organization so you can
remove your tinfoil hats. For now.
Instead, the uranium wheat is coming from
within our food and it's getting there
naturally.
Uranium occurs naturally in soil rock
and water and it can be released into the
air through wind and water erosion
and volcanic eruptions in the air.
Uranium exists as dust that
falls under plants and land,
especially during heavy rainfalls.
Once on land,
the uranium seeps into the soil and sticks
to plant roots making root vegetables
like potatoes, radishes, and turnips.
It's primary means of getting
into our diets, but don't worry.
The amount of uranium we ingest on a
daily basis is not nearly enough to do any
damage.
Luckily for us,
almost 99% of the uranium that enters
our body through food also makes a quick
exit through our feces and 70% of the
remaining uranium that doesn't go through
the back door just leaves a bit later
through urination, a tiny amount.
We'll stay within your bones for a few
months or even years after eating it,
but won't have the same toxic effects
you'd experience if you inhaled it. Now,
just because we all survive
ingesting it every day,
it doesn't mean we should be eating big
chunks of it and starting the uranium
challenge online. Eating large doses
of uranium would be very dangerous.
If you consume 25 milligrams of it,
you'd immediately start to experience
kidney damage and anywhere past 50
milligrams could cause complete
kidney failure and even death.
If you did those meals,
you still wouldn't be in the clear because
long term radiation exposure can lead
to increased chances of cancer and
changes in brain chemistry. So yeah,
if someone plops a big chunk
of uranium on your plate,
you're probably best to pass and tell
them you've had your share for the day.
And who knows?
Maybe there are a whole bunch of other
strange materials secretly entering our
bodies on a daily basis,
but that's a topic for another.
What if
we should be eating big chunks of it and
starting the uranium challenge online
eating large doses of uranium
would be very dangerous.
If you consume 25 milligrams of it,
you'd immediately start to experience
kidney damage and anywhere past 50
milligrams could cause complete
kidney failure and even death.
If you did survive those meals,
you still wouldn't be in the clear because
long term radiation exposure can lead
to increase chances of cancer and
changes in brain chemistry. So yeah,
if someone plops a big chunk
of uranium on your plate,
you're probably best to pass and tell
them you've had your share for the day.
And who knows?
Maybe there were a whole bunch of other
strange materials secretly entering our
bodies on a daily basis,
but that's a topic for another.
What if.